Volume. So, what really is volume? It's a word we hear all the time, but in math
it has a special meaning. Just as we think about it in everyday life, volume is
a measure of space, 3D space to be precise. So let's say I have a balloon, like
this one right here. It's not inflated right now, it's pretty flat, not actually
just two dimensional, but there's no air inside of it right now. To puff it up.
So right now it's not really taking up very much space. However when you inflate
a balloon, you increase its volume because it takes up more space. The volume of
a balloon is hard to calculate mathematically. The volume of a box Is pretty
easy though. Let's take this box, for instance. We can say that there are 3
different lengths that we can talk about with this box. If I tilt it a little
bit, you can see its height, this length right here. You can also see the width,
which I'm going to call this dimension, and we can look at the length too, right
here. Since this is kind of bulky to work with right now. I'm wanting to draw my
own rendition on the tablet. So here is my very fancy drawing of a box. You can
see I've labeled the length, the width, and the height of the box, the three
different measurements that we can take of it with a ruler. Now for a box, the
equation to find the volume is quite simple. The volume is just equal to the
length times the width times the height. In fact, I'm going to go ahead and
label these sides with these abbreviations. So here we go, one side length of l,
one of w, and one of h.